[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
[Laughter]
god i wish we could just can't
tampa was fun man you missed a good
weekend chappelle yeah
i did you missed a good y'all
got a good weekend something better than
others
[Laughter]
hey
was dope we stayed right across from the
stadium where tampa bay plays
oh really [ __ ] there's literally
right i saw the big pirate ship you saw
everything
yeah why didn't you wear your jersey he
got the uh like basically the swing man
jersey of tom brady
damn here's the crew ricky cruz love
rick lewis
lewis j shoppe stevie justin
those guys came up with diaz right or uh
the one on the left came with diaz the
first friends i made in uh
in outside l.a yeah like i cause
i toured i did uh orlando palm beach
and tampa and i just drove around i was
just i had no idea yes
even jay wasn't with me back then oh
really on 17.
i saw i just got a rental car and drove
by myself and those guys went with me to
all the shows
damn i love crushed yeah they did both
killers yeah ricky cruz was with uh
joey diaz came with joey diaz check him
out man it's ricky cruz and
uh louis diaz they have they have their
podcast called the bathroom wall
uh-huh it's on uh all streaming so [ __ ]
yeah they don't have video yet which
i spoke to ricky about this come on guys
come on step your game up
i've always heard that about him man
tough follow so follow yeah
so cool oh dude how about there was a
guy in the front row there's a guy in
the front row on the last show
a lot big like what'd that go do baby
like that he had a beard what that
motorcycle dude what that motorcycle
game
gang do baby like that oh beard
long hair backwards hat looked like he
got kicked out of hell's angels
drinking and sorrows away because he was
so loud during everyone's show i'm like
was he by himself no he's with a crew
he's with a crew
and he's just excited but he's hammered
and then uh
security went and talked to him and
ricky will do some crowd work
and was like what they say to you and
he's like they told me he's right by the
stage like
tommy quit talking like no don't listen
to them you're talking with me now when
brendan comes on stage shut the [ __ ] up
like
but with me we can engage man so ricky's
like lighting him up having fun with him
and he can tell the guy because he's
talking he's like he's so big he's like
kind of swaying
then i get on stage and his boy was like
the big fan i don't know if he just
dragged his big ass out or what
yeah a picture of mankind if he was in a
biker gang make terrible decisions
that's what he looked like so uh so he's
there with his crew his boys like the
fan
i dragged him out and he's just drinking
drinking and he's quiet
like i could light him up when i first
got on stage i just want to pipe him
down
yeah so i like made fun of him kept
talking about code and all this [ __ ]
and then i see him like as the show goes
on he's like this
and towards the end of my show he's
completely out not at all like this
just yeah just out of it i get off stage
me and ricky and everyone go up top and
the way uh tampa works you know it's
like a mini theater so good i've
ever been in oh so it goes here second
second level third level okay and the
green room's on the third level with the
fans oh i mean rick you're up there
there's talking about the show
enriquez look at that dude man talking
about that [ __ ] and he's still on the
security's like trying to wake him up
and his his girl's like god damn it
really it's here like looking around his
boy's like [ __ ] dude
and then finally they wake him up and uh
ricky goes i bet he throws up i'm like
no that big ass dude
show enough they wake up he goes
grabs two bare empty beer uh mugs and
just
grabs the third block fills him to the
brim
dude i don't miss that life brennan was
so dumb he was like who got to clean it
up
he paid the person to clean that up oh
man yeah
hell yeah right here put it there job
shitty she did a shitty job
no you know what i'm saying like that
sucks oh she has [ __ ] and i saw i saw
you said she did a [ __ ] no no i saw the
staff being like
[ __ ] man like they're around like last
night they're trying to decide who's
gonna clean it so i walked down like
who's cleaning up this throw up
and this lady was like it's my table
this like you know she's not old
she's just like yeah yeah she's been
there a while she's like it's my table
so i guess i have to do it
damn he's just like man i got you yeah
also
we i met a lot of ectomorphs out there i
didn't know i didn't know i was the
leader of the free world that was like
y'all
stuck all that like diet talk we got to
gain weight i was like okay cool
oh so like yo you got a crew of people
that want to gain weight with you you
know our slogan
good things come in small packages no
you have to be too young to do something
to something
to something to do small packages well
yeah you think small we trying to come
up
well we just started now as a as a it's
a this year
yeah it's a new tribe you were missed
though yeah
i was yeah dude i know it was yeah i was
sending like food texts back to me i
know right
i didn't cheat on my diet stayed strong
you know we even went to whole foods
mean stevia okay i thought i'd use
cookies
steak pork chops i bought filets at
whole foods that's what it was
and then stevie bought chicken and rice
[ __ ] yeah i had oatmeal
in the mornings yeah dude didn't do it
at all
we're doing it dawg yeah uh
because obviously white mike you know he
ain't no diet you know that
that non keto satan over there yeah he
uh
he wanted white mike sent
recommendations for tampa oh
dude best burger in town get the double
go this place drink
this beer yeah go to this brewery he
doesn't he doesn't drink i was like
drink beer he goes you don't drink beer
i go come on
come on man he talks about whiskey all
the [ __ ] time yeah but uh we went to
that joe's barbecue
man it was it was it was tough it's
tough it was just good
i got uh the half chicken with veggies
oh it's not it's still good chicken
though
it's like the half smoked of smoked
chicken what white mic it
he got the brisket the semen
there's this sandwich called the z the z
oh and it has like coleslaw
and uh uh onion on it yeah it's good
yeah bro he was
he was he was knocked out my mouth is
water yeah did he like it
yeah he liked it yeah you're my water is
[ __ ] good yeah
i know dude it was tough it was so tough
well the problem is like if you would
have been well stevie's there
so i was good jay eats the same and then
he'll eat
whatever [ __ ] you order jay and i have
like the same diet yeah whatever the
[ __ ] we had
yeah yeah but then the problem is is
justin eats like a
fortunate baby he has cookies chips oh
[ __ ]
apple juice juice bro have these he goes
off of some apple
and then he just goes man i need some
roids doug that's serious
but with that diet you definitely don't
bro
yeah he's like yo you give him roids
dogs i'm like no i swear dead seriously
that's what i mean
yeah he's like man i'm trying to know
you
get
on
the
get them like no because they looked
around he was like man i'm the smallest
guy in this house
he was like man you think he is he is
the smallest guy yeah he is the smallest
guy of the crew
he's got maybe he's well him or steve
he's like stevie's small but stevie got
him
yeah yeah stevie's like gleam but justin
stevie took off his xermax shoes his
little tiny shoes
you crowned him
you know tiger wears the same shoe well
i picked it up
he looks little shoe
[Laughter]
it's just this cute little air max huh
this is
it's just a smaller shoe yeah damn but
yeah
yeah but justin's like as far as like
pound-for-pound like yeah
this was so small i wonder how many he's
self-conscious he's 152. he's
self-conscious of it too yeah you put
one because
we went to that pro store in tampa for
the buccaneers what although yeah the
pro shop for the buccaneers
and they didn't have my size for jerseys
but they
him and justin got brady jerseys and he
got the white one he's like i was like
he looked dope and i'm like damn that
jersey's joke he's like man it's too
long man i was too skinny i'm like
have you ever looked bigger like just
rock
just run right yeah look too skinny man
because he was looking in the mirror
trying to pull it down
he's like man this don't it's too much
that's just you oh you know what we
rented a tesla out there
suv oh really how was it was it dope you
know me i'm a hater on tesla's yeah uh
it was cool it was cooler than i thought
okay it was cool i get white people what
does that look like
suv look like i know it's the one with
the the wings that open up like that bro
it's the one that dances yeah dance and
then the the
the self driving school
and they didn't know yeah it was on i'm
going 85 miles down the highway i turned
back to maligas like
damn dawg i was like
we were lit jay was all nervous he was
all near the steering wheel like this
i was like it really drives itself yeah
yeah yeah
but there's a but uh the guy who owns
the tesla
that what what's the app we used uh i i
can't remember
sure yeah yeah like for turo it's just
people's cars that you rent
uh-huh the owner had 21 tesla yeah he
was tesla and
he has porsche dropped him off
yep dropped us off he legit yeah
stevie's lucky i will
oh cause he wanted to see this tv she
really got a mouth full of dick
because he picked this up when he came
home he was a big bear
and somebody i knew he was gonna say
something and i was like he's holding on
to something he's about to let it out
right he's a big man oh really she was
like man good thing you were there in
the back seat
he was gonna take him yeah dog yeah be
careful on the streets man
i knew this was gonna happen oh really i
called it you because
he's like hey we don't because the ubers
for a reason ubers and tambo are [ __ ]
terrible same
uber it takes 30 minutes they said
something happened after the super bowl
like something with the ubers it was
like got crazy out there postmates to
everything takes
forever so i was like hey in the morning
because we had to leave at like 8 00 am
yeah i'm like let's pre-schedule uber or
get a taxi
and then stevie's like nah talk to the
guy who has the tesla's
he's gonna give us a ride i was like oh
that boy gay
and he goes now you're stevie what
guy is going to offer to take other guys
to the airport
just out of kindness mm-hmm he's like
well are you really nice like bro
i'm sure he's nice was he gay did he
come off that way oh yeah
bro he didn't tell you what he said big
too what do you say
well they exchanged numbers yeah because
they exchanged numbers he's like
if you ever come back he's like have you
ever come back i get airbnb here and
steve was like oh brendan aren't we
i was like yeah we're in naples we're in
miami's like hit me up i got
airbnb everywhere i was like yeah we use
the app man please that i mean
i'll just take my cells like steve give
him a show
yeah because uh stevie said that he had
to give him the car
at eight and the guy's like oh no i'll
pick it up from your
uh airbnb rather than pick it up from
the airport because he needs to drop it
off to somebody else at 8 30.
got it and when he picked it up he's
like oh where are you guys headed he
says oh i'm gonna go to the airport at
this time he's like oh you know what
i'll come back and i'll bring my porsche
uh to cayenne the electric car he's like
yeah i'll show you uh what it looks like
it's really cool i'll drop you guys off
to the airport it's really
and then what am i saying [ __ ] i have
my own
cars at home oh and then there's this
what before you come like stevie where's
your dude at
and he's like oh you want something from
starbucks i'm like we don't have time
for starbucks he's like nice and get it
for us i was like
and then we picked this up i was like
man you're way too nice i was like
people in la do not drop others off at
the airport like this oh
unless they want something stevie get
that big white dick up
get that big dragon dick out for this
damn let me know what you're working
with
so y'all had a blast man yeah it was fun
man let's take a little break
again because guess what ufc 259 is this
weekend this card is that's that's
a stacked three title fights
all right so that means there's plenty
to bet on with draftking sportsbook the
official sports
betting partner of the ufc
and it's putting you right in the center
of the action with special odds
for all you guys all right and once
again i'm teaming up with my
fam at draftkings i create a custom
parlay every week when there's big
fights
we get together we come up with some
odds just for you
the listeners and here are my picks for
ufc 259
if you bet on these three fighters it
will freaking
triple your odds all right so it's
plus 300. it boosts out to plus 300 when
you bet on al jamaine sterling
my lock of the week he's my number one
pick of the week
israel out of sonya and amanda nunez if
they all win their fights
all right you gotta parlay so all three
of them have to win if you bet a hundred
you win 300 but a thousand win three
grand
all right you win three grand you win a
[ __ ] ton of money all right
even better is do this with draftkings
they're boosting the odds of my b
shop parlay to plus 300. that's three to
one odds for all new existing customers
who take
the b shop parlay head to the app right
now find the brennan shop special under
odds boost tab
bet on it and ride along with me show me
your money
make it rain at the crib in front of
your kids and stuff
new users download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app now use promo
code t-f-a-t-k
when you sign up bet on my parlay
fighters to win saturday night
for ufc 259 and take advantage of all
my special odds boost that's promo code
t-f-a-t-k
if my prolly hits you'll triple your
money man who doesn't want that
only at draftking sportsbook must be 21
or older new jersey indiana
michigan and virginia only restrictions
apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
question mark call wayne hunter gambler
or in indiana
809 with it or in virginia
why don't you give 888 532
3500 a ring hey man
there's nobody else on the planet like
you so why would you buy a generic
mattress built for everybody body
if you thick like your boy here helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress just
for
you with your side sleeper hot sleeper
plush
firm with helix there's no more
confusion all right no more compromising
on average mattress
helix sleep was even awarded the number
one best overall mattress
in 2019 2020 by gq and wired magazine i
got my crib
i can't get rid of my friends family
everybody wants to sleep on these great
mattresses
thanks helix just go to helixsleep.com
fighter
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they will match you with a customized
mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10-year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will so who
cares
helix is offering you guys up to 200 off
all mattress orders
and free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com
fighter that's helix sleep.com fighter
for up to 200
off so you all had a blast man yeah it
was fun man y'all was like [ __ ] your pal
huh that was cool he was missed
okay but it's dope your headline you're
on weekends man that's dude that's the
goal for
man that's the that i mean that's the
blueprint yeah it was insane
i texted you a lot of [ __ ] people
showed up for me i text you i said you
thick comedy caterpillar oh yeah yeah
yeah comedy
you finally grew up headlining your own
weekends it was
that's that's how this business should
work yeah i i just didn't i mean because
i don't know what the [ __ ] i
i don't know anything about i don't know
it's just weird i don't know what the
[ __ ]
because yes people listen to us and you
know the views and they follow you and
stuff like that but you don't really
know
how they really feel until like you go
out and like straight
and hit the streets they show love like
with stand-up cause like we're just
doing this we don't we don't get a
reaction
from people right now you know what i
mean but like when you go out there
on the stage and you know it's like
headlining chapelle lacy
name on the marquee all this stuff you
didn't take your pictures or nothing huh
uh yeah i did did you did you post it
yeah
i didn't okay yeah true true uh
but uh it i don't know it was it was it
was crazy people were really excited to
see me like i
like when i walked out on stage every
night i was like how was that feeling i
described that feeling like when you was
i i don't know how to work on my
interview yeah i know what the [ __ ] is
yeah
yeah what is this 60 minutes what the
[ __ ]
describe that internal feeling i
actually thought about it yeah i was
like please don't answer that please
please make fun of make fun of him
[Applause]
the same what we do you look skinny that
was gonna tell you you're looking like
you're losing weight man yeah i've been
working out
every day man i'm working on the room
not been working out your man on the
left
oh bro tell him bro that's dorian this
dude
is a cool [ __ ] dude hey hey hey shoot
yeah i said that every night
uh super cool dude and he's like he goes
to like some really prestigious
uh college i could have told you that
super [ __ ] smart could have talked
about you don't wear a shark
like that so in last chance someone said
it looks like his feet and his shoes are
on the wrong
feet it does it does it's like the
rights on the left and left on the right
those are dope chelsea those rush boots
those brush boots
yeah i have a pair of those with jeans
they're dope
i think that's how they dress in kansas
city though i mean it was it was pretty
cold out there why is white michael got
like surprised i don't know i think he
was just really surprised
you know white mike gibbs he's just
excited to be out the house i love white
mike yeah
he did good uh uh [ __ ] dorian
black dude he he was good too it was it
was a fun weekend man it was
i literally was shocked every time i
walked i was like you hit that bonus dog
yeah
bonus you're buying lunch dog yeah i'm
buying lunch dude yeah
it was dude you tell your girl you hit
that yeah she knows what's up she knows
what time it is we kicking it
but yeah man it was great feelings i got
to give a lot of thanks to like
you theo brian like just for you know
helping me
you know get myself out there man like
more more me than those guys but yeah
but like
well i mean like i hear i see where you
have yeah more
a lot of people there's a lot of people
i've got to give it a long journey a lot
of people listen
to them
they're on the bench yeah but uh go to
my story yeah uh
chin yeah right there like he was just
[ __ ]
oh you're in austin for this friday and
saturday this friday instagram is gonna
invite you over for them wings
i know yeah healthy we can make them
healthy now look at that
people were excited that asked me at the
skate park but in kc
no that that's uh yesterday was that
yeah that was yesterday
you came home and went straight to the
skate park no i went i came home the
girl's like what the [ __ ] came home went
to zoo culture
then went to the skate park oh damn dog
that's my boy casey shark justice baby
uh weird to me when guys are older and
they're really good at skating
but um as you know i pulled up the zoo
culture this morning
because i was talking to mike dolce he's
like you gotta make it a priority to
train because i'm on these new
supplements he's like you gotta make it
a priority
to train i was like dude mondays are
terrible for me because i start below
the belt at 8 a.m and fire the kid back
to back
i pick up my son i can't just go work
out and he said you got to find
something in the morning
so i pushed everything back so i could
work out in the morning
drive up to zoo culture what happened
on the doors it's like sorry to let
everyone know blah blah
going in there i don't feel unsafe to be
honest no i'll lick that [ __ ] bar
yeah i mean and everybody's just in
there just [ __ ] that's what's weird
like people are going there to work on
their [ __ ]
health yeah you know what i mean like
everyone's in crazy shape
it's crazy they're like it's insane yeah
okay you know
i don't know i don't know it's not now
if it was an older gym like
it was for older people yeah i guess
yeah kobe's pretty dangerous
but if they're in shape yeah and like
yeah but if they go back home whoa
that's not on you
you're not their dad yeah if they live
with their grandma they shouldn't be
there they shouldn't risk that
but if they live with just another
person
and they're okay with it and they're in
shape yeah you're not their dad yeah
they don't owe you that but also at the
same time you think the people that are
going there are going home to people
that
are at risk no well we don't know that
but hopefully they're not in it
they have no power to stick their nose
in somebody's business that's
speculation
if i want to be a dumbass and go that
gym and then go home and
say i have a sick mom and i'm an idiot
and i do that yeah that's on you man
yeah one and your mom's gonna deal with
the consequences didn't you tell us the
goals just opened
uh this past weekend it's at all outside
oh [ __ ] my bad yeah
yeah it's all outside but again but i
mean i don't know
it is weird like i mean i've been
working out there for the past couple of
weeks now
it's the best that's my i love it you
see me hit that 225 by myself you know
i didn't watch it is it just you it's
you doing this
is you doing this are you serious is it
you doing this
i hit 225 no i saw the comments and i
was like oh tim
benjamin 225 but it was because he said
he was talking about this
only reason why because he was talking
that [ __ ] like i just got home
and then you sent that so he said
positive text he was like yo i didn't
brendan was right i don't believe in
myself yeah i said brenda was right i
was like
i didn't read any of that i just got
home
and i see all the comments because
usually i'm like damn
man it was you doing 225 on the incline
yeah yeah
because i remember you were uh you were
saying like you're like man you don't
believe in yourself
you're strong enough yeah and i didn't
well [ __ ] i didn't i didn't know
but yeah i was able to do it did you
work out that uh the gorgeous man
yeah that's what i work out with every
time mark harley zoo jim tarzan
hella mark what are you sending it it
was good man i
you know how many times you six uh five
okay
we're getting there yes you know that's
good i've done more
i'd have to see the video oh he did yeah
watch see i just said i was [ __ ]
pumped but
man i've been i've been feeling so much
better
about myself yeah like i looked down
looking good dude i
like i wasn't like uh tired like during
the yeah me neither
i was i wasn't tired of my shows no my
energy is good
my energy was up did you say uh you you
know how to stop
drinking whiskey because you feel good
you're in shape well
no whoa i didn't say i'm gonna stop
drinking whiskey i'm drinking stop
drinking as much whiskey oh it's muscle
yeah all right
yeah like on the early show i can
have you know two doubles on ice and
then uh
you know some whiskey on stage the late
show i should probably limit it to one
one double yeah because if i'm drinking
two doubles first show two double second
show
the spokane time i added two more shows
we got three shows friday three shows
saturday
yeah i mean six doubles yeah yeah come
on dude you're gonna show
like but like real talk like you felt
good like after all the working out
you've been doing it
last time we were all on the road was uh
san marcos yeah
so it's been a minute so like we was
getting bad in san marcos
[ __ ] but man i'm telling you this is the
first time i in a weekend
on like on the road where i actually
[ __ ] ate good i know i was proud both
of y'all yeah reminding san marcos we
ate that heavy ass barbecue
i went to the green room everyone's like
lethargic yeah tired it's like
we can't keep doing this man no [ __ ] no
not like you look at the way like even
kevin hart before shows eating that man
he's too locked in doug
yeah yeah owe it to that crowd to be
locked i know yeah
it's it's so important i don't know yeah
i've been feeling good man
i feel like i can run up a [ __ ]
mountain not yet but
i'm gonna get there i'm gonna get there
how about you man the [ __ ] you've been
oh man i've been lifting you can see it
um
i lifted so look yeah a whole weekend
right
i want the workout to show them i can
get 225 what did you guys did you guys
find a gym or something
no but again he was like we walked
around saint petersburg
oh okay which was i love statesman
it's very it's very old i mean i would
say oh i think it's like very nice and
slow out there
like it's like slow pace but you don't
have energy
it's dope though restaurants surrounded
by water it's a cool drive
no they drive down the highway they get
all beat like all oceans surrounded by
ocean
yeah wow but the food was nice the spot
we went to the food
it was all right it was just average it
was average yeah it was average
yeah but than that yeah i've been
working out you know all right y'all got
me on this two two something to do
something i'm gonna go to zoo culture
when i get to 200.
you know i'm one i'm gonna go in there
under two hundo
yeah no okay i saw that i saw that uh
that asian kid with the legs he was
there
with the maple leaf legs maple leaf legs
up to the light
yeah i saw i saw him in this morning oh
you saw me there this morning i wanted
to say something but i got it
kids jacked oh yes yes dude
oh that's what's talking about talking
about that hilarious wait who's that
wait
how do you get your abs like that i
don't know but everyone there's like
that that's
crazy do you see that yeah they're all
like that dude dude i told you
you got to be two something to do
something yeah you ain't getting in
there malik
let me talk to bradley no he talked to
him i just talked to him he said no
are you serious yep everyone's like not
like that going to this gym is
dude it makes you want to buy a better
gym everyone's fashionable look at his
legs yeah see his tree leaf legs
yeah that kid but again
there was one guy him and his homie were
on the squat rack
barefoot they had the the short shorts
on
i'm you should hit biggest legs i've
ever i mean
bigger than any running back i've ever
seen tall dude no oh
like maybe six foot five eleven dude
they're lit
i mean two of mine the word so
barefoot then they got hot [ __ ] next
to them squatting you're like oh my god
damn you didn't look at the heartbeat
oh my god
it really does motivate you because you
walk in there and i'm like damn what the
[ __ ] oh we look closely y'all so y'all
work out
everyone's fashionable got the shorts on
everyone looks dope
everyone looks so just everyone yeah you
can't destroy your teeth you just can't
wear raggedy gym clothes like yeah oh
yeah i do i bought i bought some uh
merch me too yeah i was like i was like
i rolled up there with some nike shorts
i didn't realize i had a big ass hole in
it i'm like
so
oh yeah i wear these shorts i bought zoo
culture
you talk i'm picking people i got this
dope ass hoodies now and [ __ ]
hats
how many cc's you boys i work three c's
it's thick
how many cc's hey so they had the hoodie
with the shirt
cutters yeah i wear those i'm not
wearing that yeah you're not wearing
that
no okay i i can't wear that one you know
why i didn't dress up
i gotta wait i gotta wait but i always
wanted to if they're like man that
shopkin comes here and just does the
same [ __ ]
every time
uh first of all that's not the video
look how easy that is
all right internet speed yeah no help
this looks like one of those bigfoot
quality videos no right
i mean you did like six five five yeah
sea dog that's good oh my god
five reps no help what you got to say
what's up brendon
did you post
that was good man yeah no i i really too
yeah
took what you said britney just got me
believing in myself dawg i'm out here
[ __ ] doing
headlining shows
enable each other man you know what i'm
proud of y'all because
last year y'all kept like we got to
start this diet another one
we all everywhere we were gonna get
there we just had to keep talking
a few times yeah scared straight man
damn damn bro now yeah we're we're
jam-packed this month though
oh yeah we're jam [ __ ] we like we we
are literally gone
every weekend so oh you're gone every
weekend yeah so yeah i'm doing awesome
this weekend right
awesome this weekend and then it's
cleveland you don't go nowhere this
weekend
no daddy
come on bro fights israel and we got a
boxing as well
so you got austin this weekend and then
we go cleveland
march 11th spokane spokane after that
there we go march 18th and then we go
maya we close
bro we just roll warriors right now and
then naples a lot of florida
yeah a lot of florida a lot of florida
on there a lot of florida i'm wearing
shorts in florida now man
stuff in that tv steve's the only one
who had shorts yeah
hot hot it was but not like scorching
hot but
i guess it is the end of february or
well it's march now but yeah still
it was it was dead i was sweating i was
thinking about wearing those big puffy
shorts uh pants out there thank god i
didn't you know my stitches
look stupid it was cold in kansas city
can't city school
it's nice out there too it looks real it
looks great
i mean what are they boring what are
they known for besides the chiefs
barbecue barbecue of course barbecue and
barbecue football
royals royals yeah so nothing past my
homies yeah oh okay
like a slow steady i did a backflip not
because it was a
bad show you wanted to no yeah one first
headline
i mean big headlines it's actually on
their instagram i don't know what's the
instagram it's pretty funny
then this dude squatted me really yeah
because he said he was a power lifter i
said i don't believe you he said let me
get on your back
yeah hold on it's called the
what is this what's it jokoy post i'll
go so go to actually go to my go to my
page uh
chin go to my page and it i tagged them
in the
photo but i did a clean ass backflip bro
it's the best backflip i've done
losing weight since i've been losing
weight bro you couldn't tell me [ __ ]
so click on it i tagged the club that's
right
yep the comic club casey yeah hey
let's get it tom papa oh yeah tom pop
was there yeah
[Applause]
they were like you need help take the
chain now
[Applause]
yeah not in a minute no gut
no good watch watch this [ __ ] dude
comes up and squats me
white people love backflips i know right
people love that clip especially when a
big dude
that was a dude his name was bo
yeah yeah bo looks strong like brock
lesnar
he wrote up his shorts comfortably dog
it's cold as [ __ ] out there
[Music]
yeah they played wonder woman
that's just one week it gets all lydia
he's at a different uh airbnb than us
that'd be sick what time you doing i
would love that
you sure oh i got a new show for you
with your uh
love doctor skit there's a show on show
time called couples therapy
ooh it's good oh you'd like i love that
[ __ ] come on now
so this is like a [ __ ] she's like the
beast of all beasts therapist
she sits down with all these uh couples
married couples
and there's like a bunch of them oh my
god it's [ __ ] it's so addicting there's
10 apples
what's on demand uh this be her
her this bee's therapist she's been
doing it for like 30 years
she be she's such a beast oh oh this two
lesbian couples fantastic
great so so what they come in
and they have really it shows it over
like a span of like a year
of them start like they start they sit
down they say their problems
and then like say like you and i are
together
and you start talking like no it's not
like that i'm not allowed to do that
she's like nope
he gets to tell his version and then you
can go from there
oh i don't dictate what they say okay so
a guy jumped and she's like nope not
your turn
it's his turn oh great i live for this
[ __ ] no no it's
such a i live for this [ __ ] it's so good
oh [ __ ] and then how many sessions how
many sessions do you have with these
couples just like a bunch a bunch
yeah watch the show huh all right sasha
i don't know dude it's a [ __ ] show
why not i don't know that's a client's
privilege
you know it's privacy no they all sign
up for this oh they all sign up and
there's one company like dude just go
your separate ways
oh really damn it so it gets it gets
pretty good
oh man there there's one uh me and my
girl there's this one girl the black
couple
well he's black she's she's like puerto
rican or something
okay and uh she uh
doesn't want him like she's super
controlling he'll go to work she'll call
20 times
he's like [ __ ] i'm working really and
she knows she was like she's super
controlling of him
oh and he's like like i can't go with my
friends i've been out with my friends in
five years
he's like because when i go out i drink
what the [ __ ] he said he pissed me
and then the one that's him right there
that's that's it right there
so then the third bro he looks so sick
man like a sad puppy
so then the therapist asked the lady on
left she's like why why
why you wanna control the narrative so
much what's going on there she's like
just i'm just i'm a very passionate
person like i'm you know i'm in the
driver's seat but she's like well let's
get to the bot like why are you like
this
and then she just tells her relationship
previous to that
the dude used to punch her in the face
and like [ __ ] her up she's like i'm
never gonna let that happen again
and then they start untangling that
really it's nuts
damn they get deep oh super deep oh my
god i'm in love with this [ __ ]
it's so good me and my girl gonna be all
over yeah i saw it it was like on uh my
yahoo news feed or something yeah
and then people were so addicting and i
was like
i'll see how many seasons is it right
now well that's the first time it just
came out
it's 10 10 episodes like if you have
dishes on demand they're all 10 episodes
check it out and then i watch that
takashi 6 9.
so you watched it just uh episode one
it's it's better than the hulu one
better than
did i show
they have a bunch of good people on
there talking about them because on the
hulu doc they don't they only really had
his uh baby mama
yeah because she's on this too but now
she's like more mature better looking
and uh that leader of trayway is pretty
gangster
does she does she still feel pretty much
feel the same way about them oh yeah
they hate each other oh they hate each
other
you know she's the one who blames him
while their six-year-old daughter is
getting like
bullied online i mean i think everyone
blames him
for that yeah okay if your dad's a you
know pisa a troll
yeah we was watching this show me and my
girl temptation island have you heard of
it
yeah oh my god was on there
she was yeah she was on there is it like
love island bro it's so much better
it's it's trying to tell the americans
it's made for you so these couples they
volunteer
to like live separately on this island
and then they bring in their exes right
no no let's bring it they bring in
hot women hot men and they have to
choose which one like they want to go
like
they're involved in and go on dates now
they live separately they put them in
separate cabanas
and they look older you know what to do
one of my homegirls was on it she
watched
yeah girl that i cheered with for or
used to cheer with like
i've known her since like 2002. she was
on it like yeah she blew up from it bro
you can't see your at your girl until
the show is over like six
or seven oh they're bringing these bad
yeah so there's like making
making who where no i'm not on him i'm
on season three chin
there's like some baddies on there and
uh
now we're they're thinking like yo so
they're like you know how dudes are we
so we see some new girls he's like yeah
let's get it
right so now the girl it takes a minute
for women to fall in love so there's
like they were nervous when dudes just
come it's a barrage of dudes just coming
in the house
now they're starting to open up and
they're starting to slowly fall in love
and the dudes are like man are we done
with these women we want our girls back
but they lost their girls you know what
i mean because they want to come on
there and just like [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
all they want to do
and then it was like yo they have to
decide at the end if they're going to
stay here
yeah they go to yeah and i'm basically
these women like some of them they just
and i'm over dating shows right now
like that i thought she was all about no
he yeah i wasn't wasting my time
you realize how stupid it is it was like
50 episodes of [ __ ]
island love island's lit 50 60 episodes
you know how long that takes to go
through
he went from super fan to [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] is this yeah yeah i was on
season but
i was i like season five i think with
tommy fury then after that it's all down
he fought this weekend by the way
he won yep he won how canelo fall as
well yeah
some bum yeah yeah then uh your boy jake
paul people came in uh
in his like ring interview canelo you
told me get the [ __ ] okay get the [ __ ]
out
tyson fury wants his brother tommy fury
to fight jake paul
yeah i don't know why jake paul would
take that fight but oh he would get
annihilated oh yeah yeah tommy's
i mean really real dog a real dog
i got ben asking on food truck next week
oh she's talking about jake paul
oh [ __ ] no skits this week right skipped
like remember they
ran and threw balloons at uh no okay i
don't think so
[Laughter]
now that he knows he's coming on i don't
know i don't think so yeah
you think he'll listen to this like ah i
got this [ __ ]
you know i don't think so that should be
hard though
no i'm not into that stuff
the worst is we got because we had tiny
tacos yeah
tiny taco place on king of the sting and
they're the funny guys there's a food
truck for
uh ben ashton if you're going to cheat
that's where you want to do it
i had your taco cat the cat only fed
only
feet only fans taco yeah oh
good oh they put their food in all this
tacos
they had the bee shop thick taco
when it comes what comes on it i don't
even know
it's just don't do it that chin's tacos
like a korean meat taco
[ __ ] it was nice all right they thought
you guys were gonna be there so they
had a bunch of extras i think that's the
one time i really wanted to have food
but you didn't have anything oh i was
here oh editing yeah
it's so good damn that meat probably
just
i one taco that was my cheat and then i
just had
like small bites just to try the other
ones you got it oh they're so good
delicious the best taco they've ever had
are they based out of here in l.a or are
they based somewhere else
uh yeah they're based out of it no
they're kind of they're outside l.a they
don't know i thought it was like what's
going on
they don't have a food truck oh okay so
it's kind of like they do
uh okay let's go we we gotta go in
business together because i'll buy the
food truck you guys make the tacos
i'd be three percent
do you want a truck or not man
[Laughter]
are you sure i told my marketing your
tacos
meet in the middle of the truck you guys
are going around town
and the tacos are so [ __ ] i
[Applause]
maybe you'll be able to march 9th what
day is that is that a tuesday
let's see yeah it is
i mean you could come here for that chin
it's at 1 30.
1 30. yeah i think i can actually make
it because we're doing cats after dark
after
all right for next week yeah sure all
right
you guys could try those tacos yeah for
sure i i won't
i was i'm gonna stick to it yeah i've
been having you could have something to
eat though
i could really yeah i'll have to eat one
talk on camera but that's it
yeah like four or five yeah you gotta
eat they're baby yeah
if riffraff can do it you can do it
riffraff did it
he bulked up because he was going to be
he was going to be like a wrestler like
wwe
he was on steroids he talked about being
on steroids never mind just kidding no
he could do that
like justin but then to
you know takashi 6'9 lost 60 pounds
possibly yeah i
saw that and so did andy ruiz lost some
weight i think 25 pounds
a bunch of fans were sending me the
takashi uh yeah
i've been having a lot of [ __ ]
support from fans with this [ __ ] yeah
bro you'd be surprised
yeah that's that's 60 pounds you got to
shave that chin strap
though that's crazy yeah his beard is
awful come on
that's 60 pounds right look at him on
the left dog what that guy dude whatever
baby yeah that doesn't look like 16.
like 60 pounds so 20 30.
that looks like 20 or 30. that looks
like 30. so yeah it doesn't look good
look at his face though compared to the
left yeah his face
is so fat look at that he looks so yeah
look i bet you that's 60 pounds
60 but he's a small dude he's that's a
lot of weight that's a ton
i'd have to see another side view but
that's a ton of weight man he just added
tattoos
yeah he had a bunch of tattoos tattoos
[ __ ] hurt
nah health is tight health is tight yeah
but you wanna you know yeah lost 60
pounds yeah i don't have a desire to use
200.
he was 200 i cannot believe he was 200
pounds how tall is this i don't think
yeah i don't think he was i think he's
like one or four pounds
yeah i don't know if i believe him but
uh
i don't think he's the most honest
person in the world
this weekend his uh his videos is so
fire his music we try to ride try to
bump into it and save petersburg
i didn't mind i didn't mind it his music
yeah jay was like he's good to work out
too or drive fast too
oh his music yeah i don't mind it it's
yeah it's it's aggressive
yeah it's just like it's loud just like
ah in your face yeah
well that's what that leader of treyway
said because he he got a prison then he
said he started a record label
and then some guys go you gotta meet
this kid uh takashi 69 he's like man i'm
not trying to sign nobody
and he's like just look at his videos he
oh no he said he came in and like was
rapping for him like in person he's like
this dude is trash
which he is you know lyrically he's
awful but then
he said he saw his videos like these
videos are different and lit as [ __ ] so
he signed him based off his videos
so he's he yeah he's got an energy thing
that he did but even takashi 69 said
he's like you know i like there's
there's guys that ups can rap better
than me he's like i'm just a better
marketer and
everything but my videos are fired and
he
video vixen yeah right what do you mean
there's no dudes in unless you're in
trayway yeah it was it was a couple of
them
no his security yeah i think so yeah
yeah
that's your part trayway yeah i ain't
part of no trade way though
that's one way to get in but that doc is
one way to get good
oh yeah i only watched first series in
show time
yeah just the first hour was better than
the show i got the
the doc showtime i mean hulu had you get
more in one episode of showtime than you
did that entire talk
oh really yeah it's [ __ ] great
uh watch the patrice oh neil doc you
watched it dude we tried we couldn't
find it yeah it's on comedy central
comedy central what not not
no it's not we tried it no no it's
probably on the app we don't have to
tell you how i've been watching it we
don't have the app
we didn't yeah no you it's free i
downloaded it it wasn't on our tv so we
didn't
try find it on youtube it's not on
youtube no it's not yeah she watched it
said it's good
oh my god it is yeah i love you you know
there's there's
there i don't think there could ever be
another person like him
he was just something different he was
so like his his biggest thing was just
being
honest he's like i have to be honest
yeah
yeah it kind of what's interesting about
that kind of hurt him too right because
like
hollywood he knew that and but like he
also didn't like didn't care
yeah he didn't really care because he he
was enjoying what uh
you know he was able to do that he goes
i don't know it's it's a
it's uh it's really good it's really
good dude how about if you go back chin
where you were before this it says burke
chrysler's machine stories about be
turned into a movie
where uh you i think you clicked on the
patrice thing
the youtube thing the youtube one
whatever you whatever the last thing is
that one right here maybe this one yeah
this one yeah see the machine story
being turned into a movie
what wow scroll down
fun fact anyone that might know burt
crutch's life is a movie long story
short when the community was in college
in the late 90s rolling stone magazine
story about crash hard partying ways on
campus florida state naming the top part
a year
at the top party school in the country
straight coming and kicking the pants
you know he was going to tell this story
on stage and rogan told me he needs to
tell on stage
he was never telling the story and he
told the story on the podcast where he
was like you that should be a bit
what and then it happened yep uh
for another you all right dude he said
long story short
um from long story short
[Laughter]
machine came out okay add
so it starts telling me about joe
rogan's podcast time you went to all
right russia
rogan curt crashed you tell a story on
stage you're welcome for that that's why
i just told you christchurch did
hone the story well viral now it looks
like machine story has
some more life in christchurch today god
he's squeezing everything out of the
story the legendary films
has optioned the rights to crash his
life once again this time develops
during the feature film
chrysler dreamer will produce the
product which is super early stage at
the moment
that's cool man damn damn we shouldn't
let that keep us from starting to cast
the film in our minds
that's big time man that's huge off a
bit he's he's lost a lot of weight too
huh
no no i think being fat is his brand
right no
no having a shirt off he can't stop
drinking
chrysler lost a lot of weight i'm sorry
uh tom
lost a lot of weight a ton of weight
damn is that him
tom's lost a ton of weight look at him
top left one chin
damn that's not fake that's fake that's
super fake yeah
oh [ __ ] i was like yo
yo girl was handsome as [ __ ] in high
school he was uh he was training with
the
bradley martin he would train there yeah
zoo culture alumni but uh anyways yeah
that doc
like i think every comedian should watch
that you should watch that [ __ ] doc
that's good huh yeah it's it's j said
it's great
yeah tried to watch it man yeah you you
got it so yeah i'd
because i had that roku tv and i just
got the comedy center the tv was
real cool yeah but we didn't have the
app yeah yeah you gotta yeah
you gotta like type in their code to
download that app yeah i'll watch it
this week
yeah i think you like it what do you
guys got for us chain cat
wait what'd you guys do this weekend
yeah we guys are awfully quiet
yeah y'all been real quiet working here
not on the road yeah not on the road
yeah i'm finishing up that move i'm like
living out of boxes right now that's the
worst yeah moving's tough
it's terrible i hate it yeah i went
camping and fishing again oh yeah i saw
that yeah yeah yeah we talked about
his story where'd you go lee kaga and we
took our electric bikes for the first
time
yeah super dope that's cool what'd you
catch
i caught a koch i caught one large mouth
bass
but it wasn't something i would eat so
kill them no no i don't know
hey what time do you leave on friday uh
my show's a friday yeah what time no i
haven't i've been booked my ticket
because i was wondering like what how we
wanted to
do this just yeah we'll figure it out
we'll either do it thursday okay we'll
figure out we'll figure it out all right
what do you guys get
all right okay so
there is a video of a older woman
i guess she's grandma and a guy who
tries to steal her purse she actually
runs after the thief
and she ends up tackling him until he
lets go of the person drives off
it's in australia yes
queensland he's all down there give me
the purse
metcalf damn
so i wonder what's in the purse he was
just like right it's her purse and he
hops back into
the truck and she ends up walking away
with her purse
grandma through a sandalwood [ __ ] yeah
that was tight
that was [ __ ] super tight if you're a
criminal
and you get hawked down by grandma and
then she debosed you out of the purse
you tried to steal
time for you to retire first of all look
at that
how do you not
how's the grandma tasha that grandma's
gangster man he had to hold down
we don't know oh wait did this drive on
the other side i forget nothing oh they
do it
that's what it is what does she get you
damn
shouts off the ground okay so uh last
week
lady gaga's uh dog walker got shot and
two
of her three dogs were stolen people
think that it was
an incident where people tracked her
down tracked down her dog walker and
tried to keep her dogs as ransom
her dog both of her dogs who were
kidnapped actually got returned to the
lapd
and it said that the person who went and
kidnapped the dogs were just trying to
kidnap random dogs not lady gaga's dogs
but now they're trying to find who the
guy was so did they did she give him the
five hundred thousand dollars
right now they're saying uh that she her
people are in talks with the
woman who anonymously returned the dogs
the woman who returned the dogs
uh we don't know her identity and she
said that she actually found two dogs
tied up to a pole somewhere and decided
to
go return it then finding out that was
lady gaga's dogs
so it's kind of sus but people it's
definitely ces yeah
there's an investigation going on
because that was a worldwide tweet that
she like put out she's like five hundred
thousand two people like
they [ __ ] the picture to the dogs head
of security got shot in the chest
it was her dog like a gay like you know
yeah just like a guy takes care of her
dog
he was like he was pretty badass if you
see the video jesus christ
wow yeah but yeah her dogs are back and
they're trying to find who drove off in
the white nissan altima
who shoots another dude in the chest
i thought he shot four times i heard he
got something like four times that's
what i was saying
or maybe shot at four times maybe yeah
[ __ ] man they caught him in the chest
that's what got him mm-hmm and then
people he's gonna do this
people yeah he's gonna recover
he's a badass dude he's badass yeah he
got he's all right
yeah there's been like robbery and
everything's been just and this one's in
uh hollywood as well
yeah the same area yeah yeah i think
it's they could be tied to the people
who are jacking people for rolexes
yeah yeah a lot of people send me those
videos
okay so hasbro
i like how you keep the real legs down
right now
so it was like watch out rolly gotcha so
hasbro has officially dropped the name
mr and mrs potato head from
their main packaging they're saying that
they're not getting rid of
the actual characters mr and mrs potato
head but from now on when they're
marketing
the toy they're going to just say the
potato heads so you can kind of go ahead
and create
whatever yeah it's just a marketing this
is just marketing yeah they're not that
woke
they're not just marketing yeah when's
the last time someone talked about a
[ __ ] potato yeah we have for this my
kids have them
oh yeah they don't give a [ __ ] to put
them [ __ ] yeah i didn't know people
were still popping with
potato heads well now we're talking
about i'm sure the same time go up
damn look what we just did right
[ __ ]
all right and then i think famous you're
a guy
uh hey this was submitted by roono72
on instagram he wants you guys to react
to
tommy fury winning his fight and being
ripped as [ __ ]
yeah he's jack so he's one what 185
right here
or something like that because you he's
uh he fights at a cruiserweight correct
what's cruiserweight uh the one right
below heavyweight oh okay
and he's not dead he has his shoulders
he's so long yeah
yeah is he still with molly bae yep she
made his shorts that he fought in
wow what was this is there like a video
of him
would he knock the dude out i'm sure oh
yeah those are the shorts she made god
he shredded yes
bodied up good looking dude yeah
i keep forgetting he's only 21 [ __ ] he's
young man young guy how old is he
21. oh yeah damn
whole future ahead of him yeah him and
tyson have the same uh
papa different moms oh different yeah
that's why he's
dark oh there's his brother
damn yeah he's pretty nasty with it
he's just young that's her dad yeah
that's awesome shout out to him yeah
shout out to tommy fury he looks good
bodied
yeah they'd let him in what does she got
okay this is um i thought this was just
really weird chris
so chrissy teigen she like begged
sort of begged just biden to follow her
and then finally
biden followed her on twitter and then
later on she's like please
unfollow me because she can't be herself
because she thinks that the person is
watching her
and she can't be herself and say you
know because it's just attention i know
and he did unfollow her like he only
falls like what 10 people or something
like that
she was one of them yeah she's just it's
like you know
when you're her you get you got to
figure out ways to stay relevant i mean
the most annoying celebrity on twitter
goes to chrissy c
you know i i'm sorry i said it because
she's chrissy
she just oh my gosh i'm replying back to
like fans
hey she just like so i'm like girl you
can't be in the house all day you
married to john legend
you know what i mean so i just i'm sorry
is john legend quiet yeah
you'll hear from him you hear from her
he's definitely more chill he's chilling
yeah
and she's on there she's out there i'm
like but this is also how she kind of
makes her money
like she's just house i mean she's no
different than an instagram thought
oh
yeah this is how it like she gets that
she's relevant
is it how she like sells her cookbooks
uh she makes a ton of money ton of money
books she doesn't
what's she famous for i don't know what
she's like she is she sports illustrates
uh swimsuit model and then married john
legend and then
she she has she has talent like she's a
personality like i know people that work
with him they say she's like
humor and witch she's a beast oh god
okay well yeah it's not a mistake
yeah yeah i i don't know much about uh
man chrissy teigen
her clapbacks it's just like she you go
to her page all you see is clapbacks
oh she's ready for it bro that's just
weird yeah that's what i'm saying don't
you have kids
yeah what are you doing now you started
starting to set in yeah that is kind of
weird
god damn i'm sorry i just had to get
that off
yeah did you hear about this plane in
bloomfield colorado
where debris was dropping off of it what
happened in this thing right yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah so this thing actually fell
down but no one got injured no one
no one actually got hurt they landed on
cars jesus christ
so imagine that you seeing that i'd be
engine exploded
and it's still flying
shout out to nine news
yeah you'd be nervous as [ __ ] oh hell
yeah
yeah i was scared yeah oh yeah so bruce
springsteen and barack obama are having
a spot uh podcast on spotify
america told calendar about this last
week yeah
check out the molding
i was like wait didn't we already know
that no i don't remember when we went to
lunch or so i told callum and he's like
i'll listen to them like that's what i
told you oh that was at lunch
yeah oh okay so i thought i know i was
like
yeah yeah so there you go though but
then bruce just got
hit with a uh dui so i wonder if
you like after the podcast announcement
oh yeah
that tornado's brand new maybe something
to talk
about i don't give a [ __ ] yeah right
dismissed
oh yeah yeah dude he's the boss guilty
cause
he looks good for his age
having two small shots of tequila it's
not bad
but then he had a commercial with jeep
and they had to pull the commercials
because
he was like driving the jeeps and [ __ ]
he got busted
there goes those marketing dollars
[ __ ]
him and obama you know i won't listen to
it but brian will
let's say an older man's podcast but
they have such a huge
huge fan base both of them oh yeah it's
gonna blow up yeah but it's
but it's not it's not like a weekly
podcast it's a six part series oh so
it's just going to be something
and him have way too much yeah
well i'll listen to it if it's only six
parts
all right daft punk after 28 years split
up
and they didn't give any actual reason
why but they're retiring they said
they've been quiet for a minute they
haven't even like they've made they've
done a lot
yeah they haven't done that last one
that they did before or anything with
pharrell
yeah the song that was sick and that was
it right
yeah that one yeah they were dope too
because they were uh
i saw an arc on rolling stones they did
an article there they you know they met
with the
writer and the guy was like it's crazy
because they had like the number one
song in the world and they're like
no one harasses them no one bothers them
yeah because
no one knows what they look like without
the mask yep that's them
similar things with marshmallow and sia
like you can find photos of them but
still you can't
a little more so now kind of yeah like
you can find photos of that marshmallow
and them like
yeah their last live show was like 2007
damn live show yeah whoa and they broke
up on the day that body
bobby schmurdo was released from jail oh
i like where you're going
why i wonder why they broke i went
because they're like yo we haven't done
a live show since 2007.
i know but why announce a breakup if you
could have stayed silent yeah
why not just what was it when was their
last album
random access in 2015 2013 yeah they
didn't
even think they didn't even tour that
record
that was a fire record too yeah they're
just [ __ ] sick of each other
i don't know but their music is i mean
just oh
as instrumentalists guitars electronic
they're great
[ __ ] beast shout out to that punk the
remember that kid that
fought the quarterback or the wide
receiver dude
yes his name is uh walker brown he set
up a gofundme
because he said that something happened
before that's why when you see him do
touches
he's gonna he can't talk about it right
now but he needs help with the
with his legal fees and then he'll talk
about it afterwards so he set up a
gofundme for like 50 grand and within 48
hours it already surpassed it
it did yeah was he at people reached out
he put as always there's more to the
story than what is
depicted in the video what is not shown
as the original assault and battery
suffered by mr brown at the hands of mr
jones
his friends shortly before capture
footage as can be seen my client's nose
and clothing were bloody prior to the
beginning of the video
he justified defending himself
um mr brown received several injured
torn biceps which will require surgery
wow [ __ ] he said he's he was laughing
with the comments about
people talking about his cowboy boots oh
yeah
yeah as soon as the cowboy boots
everything we talked about here
nice that's what's up yeah yeah great
well i hope you're behind the ship works
out for that let's see where it's at
62. oh so so he only reacts for fifty
nine
does he get to keep the third of course
oh yeah yeah
what else would they do with it dude oh
well unless
lastly check this out how cool is this
man so this uh
he shaved his face the shoes last week
chad no
we should alright guys we had this thing
was found in the
australian forest right it escaped
escaped there was no farm
and check it out that's how you looked
in the forest oh
wait that's the way nature intended to
be man
it was actually from you know a cattle
ranch before but it escaped so it just
grew all the stuff
out and it had to be shaved how long was
it out there damn i forgot how long but
look at him now
yeah damn mr steel you're right
that [ __ ] he lost 60 pounds he
probably feels so good
dude 78 pounds of wool he looked like
77.
he was like this is a nightmare i want
to go back to that farm
i can't walk look at him now though he's
killing him yeah
and his name is brock too rock
with multiple a's he got his toothpick
in his yard
look at him bro cool ass he's happy as
[ __ ]
oh yeah that's what's up man that's
what's up i like his fit too
yeah yeah that's cool all right that was
dope thanks man
yeah i better like this yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was kind of cool
yeah i'll give you that one all right
thank you god
he looks so [ __ ] good he must be
tough man bro
poor guy can't see 70 bro pounds of wool
they have to be shaved yeah yeah so
when they're out in nature what like
they're wild sheep i don't think i don't
think these are the ones that you find
in the wild so the fox wouldn't but
they're actually some wild sheep but i
mean it's like dogs you know
after a certain amount of uh human
intervention
it becomes something else yeah yeah yeah
they become like super soft so yeah i
have to depend on like pigs right no
there's wild pigs
yeah exactly like they're domesticated
pigs and they're wild pigs
yeah but are there wild sheep though
because if they have to be shaved
yeah there's no way well we've seen a
wild hog but wild sheep come on man
the wild hogs don't play around either
they're not rolling for
them they'll mess you up one other day
did where undisclosed are unable to shed
oh they can overheat and die maybe
that's just how they die then in the
wild
they die in the wild no let's say that
they are in the wild
this is us just like making assumptions
yeah maybe that's how they end up dying
yeah if any predator doesn't decide to
eat the [ __ ] that's it first because
they can't really defend themselves
either no
i'm saying like let's say a fox sees
that big ass sheep
what what how does he take him down oh
there you go natural evolution
what does this say oh see sheep had been
bred by humans for a millennia with the
goal of selecting proper ones that yeah
we [ __ ] them up
they'll produce the most world effects
interesting yeah if they don't have
human
so we just give this with our t-shirts
what
made of wool t-shirts cotton
wool is like the thicker material that
used to coat
oh it's a coke yeah it's like your yeah
you know what i was trying to
[Laughter]
shut it down like our shirts are made of
wool
polyester and valley we rolling the dice
on the [ __ ] he's saying
hey sometimes i crack up i just [ __ ]
sometimes
say that stuff i wish it was like star
trek where you just beam out of it
i love i can't try to save me wouldn't
it be like a coke i know right
yeah that's what i mean that's why i
knew where
[Laughter]
oh
most shirts are cotton okay what about
that wait uh
which one you're looking at that one
that's like a lighter
mourinho says wooly
ultralight short sleeve uh 100 marina
fabric
merino fabric oh i think merino is wool
but i don't know it's a different kind
right
yeah yeah strength there you go all
right melanie yeah
yeah let me beam him
please do if you assume the shirts
everybody's wearing
[Laughter]
like your shirt my shirt is that shirt
we all wear
so it's important it's important dog all
right we need to think about this [ __ ]
man are y'all even thinking about it
i just disappeared
that's it all right all right man uh go
see chappelle lacy
this friday saturday in austin texas hey
let's [ __ ] do it
vulcan gas company march 5th and 6th
chappelle lacey
then me and this crew back on the road
cleveland ohio march 11th through the
13th
spokane washington the only tickets
available right now all shows are sold
out so for the thursday late show
which is march 18th happens to be my b
day we're probably going to add shows to
friday and saturday so don't be mad
we'll add shows just wait for it and
then uh march 25th to 27th
miami florida miami improv get your
tickets now f-a-t-k-z.com
this thick maroon hoodie you see me
wearing will be available in maroon
black and that varsity jack you see me
wearing
on the pods and the shows the one i wore
with max hallway on food truck diaries
is available this friday
10am thickboy.com and that jacket price
point i think is either 59.99 or
69.99 either way for that dope ass
varsity jacket it's a great [ __ ]
price
thick boy nation hoodies and jackets
this friday
10 a.m thickboy.com is that it kids
that's it that's
it health is tight health is tight we're
out
that's [ __ ] do it what's up guys my
name is chappelle lacy i'm really cool
today because i got the
cool gray fours you know what i'm saying
size 17s no they're not even from here
they're not big
no see your toes out
everybody
that's why he was asking what happened
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh god all right i'll be back wednesday
i'll be back wednesday